what's the most important lesson you've
learned
people don't give a [ __ ] that's the most
important thing i didn't learn
and nobody cares
nobody cares
nobody's gonna care for you like you
care for yourself
nobody's gonna take care of you like you
can take care of yourself
all right generic yes generic where'd
you grow up where you from originally
um from los angeles south central los
angeles south central
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
uh yes i was raised by my parents were
my mother
my father was gone for 14 years
and in prison since i was 5.
what was he in prison for homicides drug
trafficking
and things like that you know
due to the game you know the game game
making life yeah how would you describe
your childhood
uh i had a okay childhood
it wasn't perfect it wasn't you know
that good but it was
you know okay any abuse anything like
that
um no i wasn't really abused
you know i just didn't have the best
life
you know like some some people
yeah and you got involved in gangs at
some point yes i did
um when i was about 12. i got put on
um athens millers and
i just you know start living the street
life
tell me how that started
well let me tell you
a little bit about my life okay
when i was three when i was three my dad
kidnapped me
um due to you know using drugs he was
off the sherm
and stuff and he took me to the
mountains he said he was going to
sacrifice me
and my mother came and found me
and that kind of like
grew anger onto my heart you know what i
mean like
why me you know why would my father do
this to me
you know it's really touching you know
i'm like
i don't want to cry i love it but
damn i hate talking about this
everybody cries here
i cry here sometimes
it grew a lot of anger on my heart you
know
because i didn't understand you know
as a kid i didn't understand why would
my dad do this to me
you know so i never had that daddy
daughter feeling
ever i used to just be like you know
f him and
it grew a lot of like bad anger you know
within
it within myself so i fought a lot
um going to school you know i fought at
school got kicked out
all my life because you know i'm a small
person
and people try to pick on me and stuff
and you know
i just was like at so much anger it's
like
i can't take that you know i can't take
nobody trying to like hurt me no more
so i got kicked out of school i went to
jail
at 15 i did a year and a half
and lost for drinking this juvenile
heart
my mother couldn't take you know she
couldn't take it you know of me
you know finding it going to school
getting kicked out and all of that
so she sent me to lost my dreamers
i got out i ended up getting put on
auntis miller's
and i ran away from the house multiple
you know living out on the streets
fighting stealing you know and
above or whatever then
i ended up getting pregnant at 19 years
old
i lost my daughter at seven months
my fault i went to court i did classes
you know i got my daughter back
i had got raped
by five people with guns
and everything you know to my head and
i ended up finding out i was pregnant
after that
and
now that i have a wrecked daughter her
name is adrian michele mays
michele eatman excuse me
and um you know i don't regret her or
anything but i didn't want her
because i didn't know which one was the
dad i don't know these men
don't know nothing about their life
nothing so
it kind of hurts to live every day you
know
looking at my daughter knowing that she
don't have a fat
you know or she don't know her other
side of family i'm all she got
it really brings a lot of pain on my
heart you know
and it's hard to live with because i
don't know how to explain this to her
once you get older
uh
it's like it's really hard living with
this
you know i lost my place
at 21 because i had fought and got my
daughter back and i had her
i had adrien because of the simple fact
the day
i was supposed to get an abortion with
her my oldest brother the one that was
really close to me
took care of me all my life he ended up
getting shot
due to the gang banging life and got
killed
on the same day i was supposed to get
abortion with my daughter
you know and it's like i feel like god
wanted her to be here you know
and he took the closest thing to me that
stopped me from going through with the
abortion
so my my brother was the sacrifice for
adrian that's how i look at it
you know and it's hurtful because that's
the only person i ever looked it up to
you know my brother was my everything
he got killed june 21st my appointment
was june 21st
and then my daughter was born 11 22 11.
the numbers are like so crazy to me
you know what i mean
then after that my first baby daddy
he came back you know he accepted me you
know accepted the situation
and he accepted my daughter as his so
she's the only father she knows so you
have how many kids
i have four now
but then i only had two you know
my oldest daughter and then the rape
baby and
my baby daddy accepted her you know as
his own child
you know because he he knew the
situation and he knew how i felt you
know like
what am i going to do with this baby she
don't have no other family i'll have no
help with her no nothing
so he stepped up to the plate and
accepted her as his child
after that i had another daughter which
is renee mays
and with my first baby daddy
because he you know start coming he came
back into my life
after i got raped you know and
we ended up having another baby
and i lost her
to the system due to drugs because i
started using drugs
after i had adrien because i didn't know
how to bear weight
you know living no more
my brother was a girl and i got a rape
baby and it just took a toll on my life
you know so i started using crystal meth
i lost my apartment i lost my kids back
to domestic violence
you know because i got into it with my
baby daddy we
argued and fought and then um someone
called the police on us
and i lost my two oldest daughters
and um that's when i started using
crystal meth
because i didn't know what i just wanted
to ease my pain you know
and then we overcame that
i quit using i had renee
but i was hopeless when i got pregnant
with right now i was homeless
you know and i was living on the streets
in the tents
and uh i said well i can't do this
anymore
you know i got to clean clean myself up
i got i can't have this baby on the
street
so i went checked into a housing program
they put me in a a placement like a
transitional housing placement
and i ended up having my daughter there
and you know living there for
about a year and i couldn't do they
they program anymore i couldn't do that
program anymore so i left the program
um i ended up standing in a bando
like abandoned abandoned house
and i started back using crystal meth
again
and i took my daughter to the hospital
because she broke out in like a rash
and they said it was from crystal meth
you know due to her skin so they called
the dcfs
and i lost her
and i had been on the streets ever since
by myself me and my baby daddy
and we was living in tents and you know
right up the street from here
um on 32nd and grad and i stayed in a
sense for
almost three years
it was hard you know and then i got
pregnant again
and i had my fourth daughter
and i i i started doing
you know i left the christmas alone once
i got pregnant again
well i smoked through my pregnancy
really you know
until i was like six and a half months
and then i said you know i said well my
babies mean more to me
you know then these drugs you know so i
have to stop using
so i stopped using for about three
months you know due to
so my system can be cleaned out the baby
can come out with no drugs in her system
and uh i end up having deanna
and right now i'm still homeless
at this moment i'm still living on the
streets at this moment
it's hard because all i want to do is
really be a good mom that you know i
know i can be
it's sad i'm not a bad person
you know it's just life is rough for me
for
the things i went through i don't you
know i don't accept
that i i deserve this life you know i
didn't ask for this
i didn't ask to be raped i had an
accident you know
i have to live on the street
i tried to go to school i tried to go to
college
i tried to better myself and it seems
like nothing never works for me
how are you supporting how are you
supporting yourself now
i sell drugs
i do gray hair i have a lot a lot of
talent
you know i pray here for a living and i
sell
crystal meth and i sell you know crack
drugs
or whatever to make you know my little
ends meet
or just to you know feed myself every
day and you know to try to like give me
a motel or whatever
to try to give me a room to take a
shower or whatever
like right now um i
i just lost everything i had right now
and the police pulled me over
they took all my drugs they gave me a
ticket
and they let me go which was a blessing
you know
but i that was my money to make
to give me a room because i haven't took
a shower in three days already
you know
i'm just like overwhelmed with my life
i'm overwhelmed i can't take it no more
i don't know what else to do i seek for
help
you know what i'm saying i'm searching
you know
i just want to better myself this that's
it
you know i don't know what else life
doesn't smell like
what emotion do you deal with the most
is it depression or anger or
depression and anger you know it's
really the present that
my kids don't have a mother that i that
i want to be you know what i mean
it's hurtful my kids is getting lonely
they tired of living with people they
want to be with me
they can't you know what i mean
i can't see them every day like i want
to
it hurt that i don't wake up with my
kids
every day you know what i mean that's a
lot of depression within itself
having to live on the streets is very
hard
it's raining out here it's cold is
really cold
you know what i mean who wants to be on
the streets no one
i don't think so
i don't want to be on those streets
i wants to give me a place i want to
have my kids
you know i want them to be able to wake
up with me
every day are they with another family
now or they're with my family members
okay granny have two of them and my
mother have two of them so there's a
chance you could get back into that
it's a check yeah i have the opportunity
to
get them back but i have to
get stable and it's hard for me to get
stable because i don't have
the income that they expect you to have
to afford a place you know what i mean
i do receive social security
but it's not enough it's not enough
you know they want you to make two three
times over the amount
for the rent and i don't get that
i don't have that so my applications get
denied
you know and i have no other choices
you know so the programs
the housing programs they they like
they want you to do this and that and
the other come in on curfew times and
all this and it's like
really hard to do it's really hard to do
you know because the little money i get
i have to pay for gas i do have a car
my grandmother helped me get that you
know so i wouldn't have to walk and you
know i can help her
come through and you know take my kids
you know things or whatever you know she
got tired of seeing me walking around
so she gave me the money to help me get
a car so i can be able to get around
you know from my mom's house to her
house you know or to my destinations
you know she's like i know it's hard out
here for you
that's like the only person i really got
you know even though my mother is here
my mother do have two of my kids
that's a blessing within itself but it's
like
my mother she never worked
you know she received social security
herself she gets section 8
and she don't have i have it you know
she's not
the mother that has it like that so she
cannot help me
you know as much so it's been a rough
life for me
you know i have to get everything like
on my own
how old are you i'm i'm 30 now i just
turned 30 july 15th
i'm too old to be living like this you
know
as i feel i should be in a better place
a better spot within life i'm scared to
talk to anybody
due to getting raped i'm scared to find
me another guy friend
right now me and my baby daddy is not
together right now at the moment
um i do have custody of my
my youngest child right now
but the reason why my mother have her
is because it's it's cold out here in
these streets
usually i have her in the motels and
stuff with me or whatever but
i tell mother it's i i don't want her
out here
i want better for her you know i don't
want to be tagging
no baby along with me with this
lifestyle that i'm living
it's not right she don't deserve that
if you're at home with my other daughter
because she have custody of my my third
child
but if you at home with with her you
know let her sister be with her
you know it only makes sense
this baby don't want she don't you know
she need a good meal
cooked meal and stuff like she's
sleeping in a warm bed
every night i don't want to be putting
her bouncing her from room to room
you know it's okay for me i'll be okay
but my baby is not quiet out here in
these
trees like that and they really hurt
you know my car is a mess right now
it's filthy in the car because i have so
much stuff because
i have my stuff plus this baby stuff
you know sometimes we have to sleep in
the car because i don't have
you know i don't make the money to get a
room you know
and it's pitiful it's sad
do you see the world as a a cruel place
or do you see that maybe you're
you grow up into a family and
environment that was
tough very different than most people
sometimes i do see the world as a little
cruel
you know from the cruel people that's in
it you know because they kind of like
really [ __ ] me up
you know within my head excuse my
language but
it just seems like the cards were
stacked against you because you didn't
have
the parenting that most people that take
for granted and perhaps the
opportunities and
stability and all the things that many
people take for granted
you had none of that and i i will i
would love that you know
i would love that yeah you seem
intelligent you seem willing
capable i'm very intelligent i'm very
smart
you know i have lots of common sense
you know
i know i can do better i know i can't
but life is so hard and tough right now
on me
you know and things have happened to me
that
you know really like messed up my mind
you know to where i cannot focus
like how i would want to focus you know
because i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared
to do anything like
what are you most scared of people
so i don't like them
because i don't know what they can do to
be
you know they tried to take my life
i pleaded for my life when they raped me
i pleaded for my life in a spirit
and that's really you know hard
to deal with and i've been living with
this for nine years now
and now that life is like
i don't know which way to go you know
i don't know what to do
don't wanna i don't i don't want no guy
friend
i can't even get a guy friend because
i'm scared to talk to them
you know what i'm saying
because like what's your motive you know
why you want to talk to me why you want
to why you want me to be your friend why
you want my number
i have to ask a thousand questions and
above
and i don't want to do all of that i
shouldn't have to i shouldn't have to be
scared
you know what i'm saying it's like
really hard to cope with people so i
stay to myself
i stay by myself
jasmine is the first friend i've had in
a long time
a long time
i don't deal with no people on these
streets not even my own homies
that's from my hood
i uh you know i stay in my my area you
know in the hood
it's because you know this is where i'm
from like i put on this hood
you know but as far as hanging
chilling you know kicking it
i don't do that with them but if you go
to another neighborhood do you get
i don't go to no other neighborhoods
what happens if you do
i mean i get respect because of the
toughness that's
in me you know what i'm saying
i i have you know been in different
areas or whatever but
i go there to sell my drugs what what
could happen if you
went out of your gang's area
uh i can get killed
you know i get shot at
i can get into fights quickly
because this side can be crips this i
you know i'm a blood so
you know if i go in the wrong area these
are crips you know they can jump on me
they you might feel like you know [ __ ]
why you over here you know what i mean
like you're in the wrong area you feel
me banging with you banging
so it's like a real tough situation
to like really live with you know i'm
saying you got to be
a little tough you know what i mean you
got to have a little heart
can't be scared but i'm
really truly scared within myself though
you know because now i have to
be this person that i don't want to be
so people won't [ __ ] with me
you know what i mean i have to carry
knives and
and uh [ __ ] maze and you know
[ __ ] weapons or whatever because i am a
small petite person
and if these you know if i go in the
area and they feel like they want to
jump on me because of the
set that i i claim
i might have to protect myself you know
what i mean
so yes i might have to pull out a knife
and shank a [ __ ]
then i gotta take your life
and all of this is like it build up a
lot of like
man i don't i don't really don't know
how to explain it you know what i mean
the life that i live but this is how it
is
i'm not no killer but don't push me
you know what i mean if i have to do
this then this is what i got to do
because i i got to eat too i gotta i got
to feed myself
you know what i mean i'm not trying to
come step on nobody's toes i ain't
trying to come disrespect y'all set
you know what i mean but if i'm over
here in this area and i see his money
getting made over here i'ma come try to
make me sad
because i'm only trying to
make my ends meet so i can be okay
because i don't have nobody else out
here i have no help
i don't have nothing out here you feel
like you're on your own
i'm out here on my own you know
the only thing i have is my mother and
my granny taking care of my kids
and that's the only thing i'm grateful
for
other than that i have nothing
i'm just out here by myself
no place to live you know what i'm
saying sleeping on the streets
sometimes i have money for food
sometimes i don't
my friend helps me sometimes you know
just to get a meal
jasmine you see me every day you know
she knows what i go through
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
people don't give a [ __ ] that's the most
important thing i didn't learn
and nobody cares
nobody nobody's gonna care for you like
you care for yourself nobody's gonna
take care of you like you can take care
of yourself
so if i don't start you know trying to
change no one's going to change anything
for me
[Music]
you know so i have to seek out for help
for myself
you know what i mean i have to reach out
to
people
so i can do better for myself
it's all about yourself because no one
else cares
you know even family members they don't
care
because they feel like they have their
own life in their own situations and
they own bills and problems so they
don't want to help
the next not knowing
that
their family member or their cousin or
brother or sister is out here
really losing it you know what i'm
saying i'm going down the drain
you know what i'm saying just a little
bit of your help you can't probably
build me up a whole lot
you know give me a little bit more
strength if you just care
a little bit but by
you not having a support system or a
support team
you you bound to drown
i appreciate my only friend right here
she gave me the little bit of strength
to keep me going
you know i cry every day in my car
i sit in the car every day i stay in my
car
and i cried because all i wanted all i
wanted to do was have
a better life you know better things
want to do better i want to do better
for me
and my kids because they don't deserve
this
you know i just want to be here for them
you know i want to show them that i do
care i care for them
and i will always care because i see
that nobody care for me
i don't want to give up on myself
because that's where i'm headed to i'm
ready to give up because i don't know
what it turns to me
it's hard it's hard it's hurtful
i don't i don't know
i'm gonna make your day a little bit
easier
i'll appreciate it thank you very much
you